hello I'm going to answer some important
questions for you on how to program a
Ford key and key fob stay tuned hello my
name is Derrick and welcome to hindsight
101 well you learn about things that
will help you in everyday life now I
made a video a while back about how to
program a Ford key and Ford key fob and
there were a lot of questions a lot of
them were the same questions but there
were a lot of questions so I just wanted
to answer all those so everyone can be
informed let's get started now the main
question everyone always asks is how
many keys do I need in order to program
an extra key well that's kind of a
tricky one so you're going to need two
keys no matter what in order to program
a spare key if you don't have two keys
then unfortunately you're gonna have to
go to the dealership or a locksmith or
Hart some hardware stores but if you go
to the dealership know that it is going
to be expensive so what do I mean by two
working Keys you need two keys that if
you put it in the ignition it will start
the car that is two working keys if you
have that then you can program a third
key if you don't you're out of luck but
there is one caveat if you have a remote
start I do not have one I'll link a
video below kind of demonstrating that
but basically is your remote start X
just like a key so what you would do is
you would press the remote start button
while you're in your vehicle the
dashboard will light up but before the
car actually turns on you hit the brake
and that signifies your first key turn
and then you take your normal key you
turn that and then turn it off and then
you take your unprogrammed key put that
in to program it I'll link my video
below so you can see that one as well
the next question is it doesn't matter
what type of key you have you can have a
key that has the key fob attached you
could have a key fob and then another
key that has a different type of key fob
it doesn't they don't have to match they
just have to work or you could have a
just a plain key that has no key fob or
you could have a key that doesn't have
the key fob attached to it any four of
those will work so you could take two of
those any four and as long as they start
your vehicle you can program them to
program a second third fourth how many
keys you want
up to you now that leads into my next
question is where do I get my key from a
lot of people get their keys from eBay
hell I got my key from eBay but you have
to be careful you want to make sure you
have a good return policy because the
first key I got didn't work it would
start the car
but the key fob wouldn't unlock or lock
the doors the third keep the second key
I got a little more expensive but it
worked just fine but both sites said
they would work with my vehicle so
whatever in the comments in my video a
lot of people said they got theirs from
Amazon and they work pretty well so you
would have to pay more for that 30 bucks
as opposed to 10 or 6 dollars depending
what you get but a lot of times the eBay
they just want to sell a key they could
care less if it's gonna work or not
they'll just say it does so you have to
kind of be careful about that but those
are the three main things that people
really want to know about programming
their Ford key so I hope this helps if
you have any more questions just submit
them below thank you like and subscribe
take care